make a whole lot of noise for the man
you came to see Josh
W keep it going for chance
[Applause]
everybody yeah man what's going on
everybody we all
good yeah well first of all thank you so
much for coming out to the show tonight
welcome welcome welcome I want to let
you all know real quick for those of you
who came to see some really intelligent
life-altering comedy you've come to the
wrong
show if you're here to turn your brain
off for like an hour and a half and
laugh at some [__] silly [__] welcome
to my world here we are you know what I
mean now I do want to say before we get
started uh it so we just moved from
California and um we're that's what all
it deserves
um we uh we're not quite used to the
humidity
yet it is anybody else not used to
humidity walking around it's crazy
here's how you know by the way you're in
a city that has a lot of humidity cuz I
saw dudes walking down the street today
like
this oh you got to shake it off your leg
one time in Nashville it is [__]
sticky sexy in here I will tell you what
it was stuck to my leg like a fruit
rollup all day
today and on both sides like a bat on
the wall
again now I'm looking out I did see a
couple of women don't hey don't oo if
you see a guy do this don't you
oo he didn't stick his hand he
didn't he didn't stick his hands down
his pants this dude he's a
gentleman you see a dude do this you tip
your hat and you say good day sir to
that guy and you let him walk
by I'll tell you something else too and
this is it ladies we love you but I
can't I can't hear one more woman
complain about watching a dude adjust
himself in public I can't hear it's so
hypocritical especially considering down
on Broadway today I was only there for a
half an hour I saw at least six women in
jean shorts do this
[__] you and your [__]
you you guys go in with two hands too
and you make eye contact you're
confident you're like what [__] you what
you know one woman went in deep deep I
swear when she went like this I heard
her I heard I swear I did like you know
like you're opening some biscuits or
something I can't hear it anymore you
know but Happy Father's Day everybody
Happy Father's
Day now um Father's Day oh thank you so
much I appreciate that now I have a lot
of favorite stories about all my kids
but this one is my absolute favorite
story about my youngest son and um so
here's a couple things you need to know
about him going in first of all my
youngest son here's what I love the most
about no matter where he is that's the
best place he's ever
been yo that dude does not know how to
have a bad time he look and it's a I
envy that attitude does and by the way
look his energy is crazy I could put him
down at any of your tables he could talk
to any of you for an hour and you'd be
like I know this dude for a decade like
it's crazy that kind of I don't even
know you called it skill but it's it's
born you know he is also the dumbest of
my three
kids
now he's not dumb I'm not saying he's
dumb but who has multiple kids in here
anybody have multiple kids hey look if
you got multiple kids you've got a dumb
one too that's all I'm
saying they may not be stupid but
there's a stupidest one out of all of
them that's the dumb one and I'm going
to tell you something
else if you got more than one kid you
have had this conversation with your
partner in the
bedroom what the [__] are we going to do
with the dumb
one we're going to let him walk out
there by himself he's so [__] stupid
you know what I
mean here's my favorite story about my
son so uh a long time ago long time ago
um when I uh was a single guy I used to
take the kids down to Mexico and um on
day trips and because Mexico I lived in
Southern California it was cheap you go
down there $50 it's a new culture you
know what I mean it's a new country and
super cool adventure you know so but you
couldn't go until you were
seven so by the time Jakey turned seven
I was married and but he was like I want
to go to Mexico and I said cool and he
was guys driving down to Mexico he was
pumped the whole way right just [__]
pointing things out he's like is that
Mexico I'm like no that's Depot
um but we're driving down there we get
to Mexico we're there for about an hour
and he turns to me he goes ha dad I love
by the way he has always stood like
Forest Gump I have no idea why this dude
has always he used to he was a great
baseball player he didit a double and
slide into second and he' pop up like
this and I
was I was always like great hit buddy
put your hands down great
hit not bad you
know so we're there for an hour and he
goes H dad I love
Mexico everybody here is so smart and I
was
like
what makes you say that man he goes H
they all know how to speak
Spanish and I was like oh come here you
dumb [__]
okay Daddy's going to take care of you
for as long as he has to I
guess you're going to live with me till
you're 40 aren't you
buddy we were there for another hour and
this dude decides he can speak
Spanish cuz to him it sounds like
this and I go hey man hey
hey I said do not speak the
Spanish and he goes no I know how to
speak it I go no you don't no I
don't so we walk around for a while we
end up going to a restaurant you know
and we sit out and the dude drops two
menus and in English he says to me what
can I get you to drink I said I would
love a medel please he said absolutely
and in English he says to my
son what can I get you to drink young
man my son's looking at the menu and
he's
[Applause]
like
and he
goes Mexican Coke I go what are you
saying to this dude and he walks away I
go Jakey what' I tell you ma'am do not
speak the Spanish and he goes no I know
how to talk it I go
no and he got really cocky he
goes he took my
order I was like you said the word Coke
bro you know what I
mean I said listen man I know you don't
understand this and I don't I know you
don't mean to but you're insulting this
man's culture and his Heritage and his
language and you're doing it right to
his face and I'm telling you right now
that's not okay so under no circumstance
are you two speak the Spanish ever again
do you understand me and he goes yes Dad
so we finish of our food
right and uh because I tell him not to
speak the Spanish he's silken and he's
like I just want to go home I said all
right he goes can I lay down in the back
seat and go to sleep and I was like
sure so we're driving up to the
border and uh the border patrol guy he
says to me he goes uh can I see your ID
and I said yeah and he
goes great he said you get a birth
certificate for the
kid I said no why do I need a birth
certificate for my kid and he said well
I got to make sure every child that
leaves Mexico is a mexican'
how do I know he's not Mexican and I was
like so I said
Jacob speak the
[Applause]
Spanish this dude's head popped up from
the back seat
[Music]
like and the guy just looked at me and
he looked at him and he was like have a
great
day we're driving out of Mexico right 15
minutes no we neither one of us said
anything and he's just looking out the
back window and it's rolled down he's
got the wind blowing in his face and I
just hear him Mumble under his
breath I told you I know how to speak
Spanish [__]
dick now listen guys uh if you've never
seen my show or know much about me oh I
I enjoy weird [__] uh I enjoy things
that are a little different I enjoy fun
and energy and I will tell you a lot of
weird things have been happening at my
shows and I think I kind of invite it uh
it started and I and I'll tell you when
it started it started about four years
ago I don't know if any of you have been
on my YouTube channel and have seen have
you seen the video of about the woman
throwing up in her Margarita
cup okay so I just need to give you guys
okay all right for those of you who
haven't seen this video this is a actual
video It Happened I just happened to be
filming my set that night I was on stage
at a casino in Connecticut called
mohagen Sun I was just filmm you can see
this video on my YouTube channel and I
was talking to this side of the
room and from behind me right here I
just heard w
and I turn and I look back and there's a
woman sitting right here staring at me
like
this and I was like oh my God and I
didn't want to throw her out because
obviously she wanted to be at the show
you know what I mean so but I I was like
I wonder what she's going to do with
that you
know they were drinking these giant
Margaritas she had had an empty Cup in
front of her this is all on video guys
she grabs the cup she slowly brings it
to her like this staring at me the whole
time and just
goes like like she was feeding a baby
bird it was some prison [__] she just
St but I was like all right you know
I'll tell you we want to know the real
reason I wasn't worried I don't know if
any of you have tried to throw up in
your mouth before that's not easy and
the fact that no nothing came out the
sides I was like well she's done this
before
so I don't need to worry about her she's
a professional you know what I mean
like 15 minutes later again all on video
talking over here again and I
hear and there she
is
her friend who's sitting right next to
her I see her lean over and I think
she's going to say
hey we should get you out of
here but she leans over and she goes
hey get your [__]
together that's a good friend by the way
that's a good friend a bad friend is
you're doing great this is great A good
friend is you're a [__] grownup get
your [__] together you shouldn't be
throwing up in public you're 40 Sally
that's a good
friend I'll tell you the weirdest maybe
the weirdest thing that's happened at
one of my shows and then we'll get into
it happened about three weeks ago in
Indianapolis so okay
uh so I was talking to the crowd and I
said who's got kids and there was a man
and a woman there who were clearly
together arms around each other whisp
whing in each other's ears nibbling on
each other and I'm like oh look at this
this couple loves each other you know
and I go how many kids you got and the
dude goes I got I got three boys I go
and the girl the woman goes I got one
girl and I go oh are you not married and
she goes oh we're married and like oh
and the guy goes just not to each other
and I was like
what
now I I thought it was going to be like
they're cute you know they were both
separated and that's how they get into
talking about each other that were're
both married ha right so I was like oh I
go so the other the other your partners
I mean they know you're here together
right the guy goes I [__] hope
not and I said dude you're so confident
talking about this in front of a room
full of people and he
goes yeah I live an hour from here I
don't know any of these
people and then from the back of the
room in the dark you just hear a guy guy
go I know you Mark and I was like oh
[Applause]
Mark you're [__] bro you're [__]
Mark anyways guys I have to tell you how
excited I am for this show tonight not I
I I'm gonna tell you a little something
about me man as an artist one thing that
I love to do is I love to challenge
myself I love to do things I've never
done before it's really how I keep that
energy of doing this all the time to
play guitar on stage and be able to do
this
um is such a crazy opportunity I feel so
lucky to be here with you guys tonight
so thank you all so so much for coming
and sharing this with
me I
um I can remember an hour and a half of
my standup I can't remember the songs so
that's the set list right there um and
so uh so I had always wanted to uh um I
got some parodies I got some Originals I
had always wanted to uh write a song
about a dude with man
[Laughter]
boobs so uh is this is this good where
the mic
is that's what the [__] I'm about to do
bro I think I sat down with a guitar in
front of a microphone bro oh you need
play something so he can hear it yeah
yeah yeah oh you got again sorry for
being an [__] okay
[Music]
uh okay
uh listen guys here's a couple things
now one of the reasons I'm nervous doing
this in Nashville is because there's
probably some musicians in the crowd I
do not want you to be offended by by my
guitar play the reason that this isn't
plugged in is because when I plug the
guitar in I find you can really hear
what it sounds
like
so way better I like my guitar Mike
adjacent look at you two guys how old
are you guys
18 that's how both of you laugh I've
never met you before but I know you both
[Music]
go we'll get back to you guys
later all right song about a do with
manoo here we
go big old titties on my friend
Dan okay here we
go I had to get that out okay here we go
here we go
bigle titties on my friend
Dan never seen a SE Cup look so good on
a
man all right here we
go at the swimming pool putting on some
suntan
lotion greasing up those bad boys in a
roundabout
motion you know Dan he could win a wet
t-shirt
contest areolas like salami nipples like
sausage and oh yeah Dan's got a nice so
R in a couple of years they're going to
swing to his
back and oh yeah Dan's got a nice old
rack wonder if he knows they make me
tingled in my
[Music]
S come on
Dre he's got
nuts and a
dick he's also got a pair of big old
jiggle I know it's probably don't ask
don't
tell but wonder if every titty [__]
himself big old titties on my friend
man never seen a SE Cup look so good on
a
[Music]
[Applause]
map give it up for Dre everybody one
time
now I I told you I liked weird
[Applause]
[__] hey man did you suck a
titty maybe I should have saved that to
the end I don't know follow
[Applause]
that wait till you see what the next guy
whips
[Applause]
out all
right so my uh my buddy called me not
too long ago and um he was like man I
gained a bunch of weight over quarantine
and I developed a very specific
problem um will you write a song about
it and I said
absolutely here you
go well I gained a few pounds Bell's big
and
round I lost my junk under my
gut thanks to the Rona I can't see my
boner I'm sorry that's so stupid
[Applause]
okay hold
on thanks to the Rona I can't see my Bon
and my balls are somewhere near my
butt and I saw the surprise in my wife's
eyes when she saw my pubic
hair she said you need a trim I don't
know where to begin but I'll never find
Walo in
there that's all I got right now
uh apprciate
it um this next song
um I'm for sure going to lose a couple
of you on
um but I don't know if you guys any of
you remember that song
my name is Luca yeah all right here we
go here we
go I see your
FAA okay you can't laugh at man boobs
and not at foa that is not okay either
all the jiggly body parts are funny or
none of the jiggly body parts are funny
but you don't get to [__] pick just
cuz you might have one doesn't mean that
shit's not funny so either you laugh at
both or you laugh at neither but you
can't [__] pick and choose everybody
okay okay now if you don't know what a
FAA is that's legit ask your neighbor
somebody at the table next to you
definitely knows do you guys know
neither one of you
[Applause]
know listen man you know just teaching
the youth the important stuff you know
what I
mean okay here we go all
right I see your
foa your [__] has a second floor that's
all I got right now but I think it's
going to be a pretty good song once I
finish it I think that really is going
to be a [__] good
one now it is Father's day and then uh
people ask me all the time about
Father's Day gifts and I think Father's
Day is
super super Interesting Man the
difference between Father's Day and
Mother's Day you know I'll tell you
something right now you know what I
really where're the fathers in here
Round of
[Music]
Applause I'll tell you what we all want
and I think this is uh pretty
Universal we would like you to leave us
the [__] alone for an entire day yeah
that's it you don't have to do anything
except open the front door and not come
back for a while that's
it and you know the difference between
Mother's Day and Father's Day Mother's
Day is like I'm going to go to a spa I'm
going to go out my friends I'm going to
have a nice dinner and Father's Day
somehow we're all [__] doing
something together I don't know how that
works we're going out to your favorite
restaurant this is my favorite
restaurant I had no idea this was my
favorite restaurant I've never [__]
been here before whose favorite
restaurant is
this so um you all their fathers day I
just thought I would sing a couple of uh
you know my kids always asked why I
don't sing songs about them and so I
remember one time they were like can you
sing a song about us and let everybody
know how you feel about us and I was
like
Yep this is for the
[Music]
kids children are beautiful they're
Little Miracles of Life what what you've
always wanted for you and your
wife but bless their little
[Music]
Souls children are
[__] and my kids are
[__] your kids are
[__] cuz all kids are
[__] it's going to be okay everybody
when you were pregnant oh it looks so
cute then you get them home they just
eat sleep and they poop do you know a
baby can scream like a pterodactyl for 7
hours in a row nobody tells you that
[__] do you remember disposable income
do you remember you could [__] in the
kitchen
do you know the average cost of raising
one kid is 500 Grand and I would sell my
kids for
[Music]
that I guess I'm not alone on that one
holy
[__] that's why I smoke a ton of
weed cuz children are
[__] and and my kids are
[__] and your kids are
[__] cuz all kids are
[__] unless you're this person not
my
son my son's not an [__] he's perfect
my little amethyst or you [__] his
name's amethyst or stone or seed or some
stupid [__] like
that not my little amethyst he's perfect
it's like having another grown-up at the
house he doesn't do anything wrong and
we let him have whatever opinion he
wants because we think it's is important
that he expresses himself fully all of
the time and we want him to be a
butterfly and to spread his wings and
just to spread his wings and fly that's
why when you're at a restaurant we let
him run up to you and scream in your
[__]
face cuz he doesn't have any rules he's
a butterfly fly amethyst fly we want you
to fly amethyst fly fly I am with this
fly and if you're that person guess what
you are the
[__] all kids are
[Applause]
[__] oh I see we've all encountered
one or two of those parents
[Music]
before um I will tell you man you know
obviously we all love our kids and and
uh we all have certain things about our
certain kids that we love the most and
and so one the things that I love the
most about my daughter is my daughter
was the most creative young person I had
ever met and ever come in contact with
and like she you put mac and cheese down
in front of her and she would just do a
mac and cheese dance or if you gave her
a hamburger she would make that
hamburger talk to you and give it a
voice and we would give her a doll and
she would write a play for the doll and
you would watch it in the living room
like a half an hour later just it was
always creativity and I loved it so when
she was 6 and A2 years old my wife and I
we bought her a cat and she said I would
like to write a poem about that cat and
read it at the talent show and I said
okay so this is the poem that my
daughter wrote about her cat that she
read in front of the entire
school and I just put it to
[Music]
music ooh I love her my
[__]
I like to hug her my
[__] yeah my [__] likes to run around
my [__] she makes the cutest sounds my
[__] she can be
scary I
[__] she's really
hairy
see yeah my [__] sleeps right on my
chest my [__] she likes my brother best
my
[__] she's as happy as can
be and she's part of the
family yeah she likes to sleep all over
the
place
my [__] should lick your
face oo my [__] should lick your
face thank
[Applause]
you I want you to know when she opened
with who I love her my [__] I turned to
my wife I'm like hey we got to
go she said why I was like the chorus is
my [__] like she's going back to it at
least a couple more times we we got to
get the [__] out of here you know she
goes yeah but if we leave she's going to
be humiliated and I said yeah but if we
stay we're going to be
humiliated we got to get out of here you
know we stayed my wife is a better
person than I am and so we're waiting
outside of the auditorium for the kids
to come out and the parents come out
first and look we all know we live in a
generation with some judgy [__]
parents and they were streaming out of
that Auditorium walking past me like
this and one woman just walked up to me
and she goes you know you really ought
to proof read your daughter's poetry
before she reads it in front of the
whole school and she walked off and her
husband walked up to me and goes your
house sounds fun you just high five me
[Applause]
like
I will tell you man and and I love
having my wife here you know what um and
I should probably explain this on on
father look she knows this but I love
bothering
her I do little things to bother her if
you're married to someone and you don't
constantly [__] with
them because here's it's the perfect
audience cuz where the [__] are they
going you know what I
mean yo I have this one long hair on my
eyebrow that gets real long and I'll lay
in bed next to her and I'll twirl it
like I'm a super villain just
like She [__] hates it you know what
else I do when she's in the bathroom and
I have and I and I take my socks off
where do I put my socks babe in my
pillow cage
yeah and like 10 minutes in she's like
what's that smell what is that
smell he [__]
sucks just so you know ladies when you
say don't do that it bothers us I'm like
well I got to do this for at least
another month then I
guess so one of the things that I've
always done to Beth is she loves love
songs I love ruining love songs for
her um so what I'll do is I'll write
parodies for songs that she loves so she
never hears the words that she
[Applause]
likes and so this is one of the songs
that she loves and a long time AG ago a
couple years ago I did some research
online and I found out there are guys
out there who have tiny penises and um I
imagine that those guys get to have sex
every now and then I also imagine that
that sex is probably pretty awkward for
everybody involved so this is a song
about a dude with a tiny penis having
awkward sex and it's from his point of
view and this song is not about me okay
here we go
uh and guys if we if you don't laugh at
this we're all going to assume why so
yuck it up you Tiny Dick [__]
Here We
Go song about a dude tiny penis awkward
sex his point of view not about
me ready
go say something I'm right on top of
[Applause]
[Music]
you be patient I haven't hit my
grew the least you could do is kind of
[Music]
move please say something I am inside of
[Applause]
you am I
am I really that
small I've been told that it's skinny
but it's
strong and it won't hurt you at
all am
I am I really that
small maybe your vagina's kind of big
like throwing a hot tug down a
hall say something I'm right on top of
[Music]
you stop tweeting that is just [__]
rude two more pumps and I'll be through
please say something I am inside
[Music]
you thank you very
[Applause]
much so listen let's start let's get the
screen here's the deal now you guys are
about to watch a video one of the things
that happened doing here in Nashville
it's been a ton of fun with these is
I've been shooting music videos and uh
we shot one a couple weeks ago to a
parody uh we're going to run in back
real quick uh we're going to do a quick
little costume change bring a couple
guests out but while I'm back there
changing it up please enjoy this
video I me to juice real quick this Kurt
Chambers on guitar over
here and this is Miss Taylor Lyn hi'
everybody
hello now uh tayor uh she came to me
about writing a song together and do you
want to tell her tell everybody why yeah
I do you were the perfect person to come
to my grandmother is Loretta Lynn and
she writes
yeah she writes her truth and it's my
10year anniversary with my husband this
year and we've really been going through
yeah some new stuff we're in a new
period in our marriage and so I came to
Josh we could write a song together she
wanted to write a song about something
that her and her husband have been
talking about and I just think it's
probably pretty Universal for a lot of
couples and so uh but I thought I would
we would put it to a song that um that
Beth liked also uh so we could ruin that
one as well
yeah um but uh whenever you're ready I
am yeah yeah oh wait a second wait a oh
oh whoa oh Tiger shoe I didn't put my
shoes on that's right cuz I felt like I
should come out in my uniform feeling
just as sexy as I could I like your
sparking pant yeah well this is Conway
Twitty's wife shirt is it
yeah
well yeah his widow what's that
[Applause]
nothing all right here we
go
what
e
tell me something
girl are you ready to give it a
worldland we can take it
slow whatever makes you the most
comfortable and you told
[Music]
me we could try it on our 10th and
anniversary well my
dear decades up the time is
[Music]
here tell me something
boy will you go first I'll use a toy on
you why do you seems
scared you want it so bad it you could
go first it just seems
fair you tell
[Music]
me for better words From Here to
Eternity but what's
up what's the big deal we do lots of
crazy stuff
this ain't no
BJ this ain't no Ro play we're talking
about an
[Music]
[Applause]
now I was trying to hold it in oh my God
okay okay okay about an on
[Music]
now why should I do it if you won't go
through it we're talking about anel
[Music]
now
you
no Rock scissor paper a no
we're talking about anal
[Music]
now
no
no no no
no no
no I'll try a
finger don't let it linger we're talking
about Angle
now if I'm being honest I'm scared that
I like it we're talking about an no
[Music]
[Applause]
now
no you first say a
no Rock scissor paper
an we're talking about an
[Music]
[Applause]
now miss Tay ly everybody that are here
one time thank you all so much thank
[Applause]
you
oh you were backstage for that part of
the show weren't
you
yeah all right um well listen I guess
I'm stuck in this outfit for the rest of
the
show I'll switch back to I'll switch
switch back to the hat that makes me
comfortable um but I'm gonna play you
know I really love
uh yeah I'm going to can I get my hat
right now
uh is
that feels a little better all
right um okay so uh I I love dudes who
play sexy music and sing about things
that aren't sexy and so I wrote a couple
of tunes this one I wrote man um my
buddy a while ago he was like hey can
you make a video with me and put it on
top of my dating
profile it's getting pretty competitive
out
there and I said I don't know what that
means and he was like let's just make a
funny video and put it on top of the
dating profile I go okay and so we did
it and by the way super funny but
nothing he said about himself was
real and I was like how do you not you
don't tell the truth on dating profiles
he goes no nobody does you just he said
you just show up and figure f it out and
I was like and he said if you had a
dating profile would you tell the truth
about yourself and I go yeah and he said
would you do a video and I said no I'd
probably write a stupid little song so
this is the song I would have on top of
my dating profile to tell you a little
something about
[Music]
me all
right you know that I want you
baby
you know that I got you
baby you know that I need you
baby so come let me please you
baby but I [__] with my sock
[Applause]
song and I [__] with my black sock song
girl and I [__] with my socks
song and I [__] [__] with my black sock
song
girl got bad circulation
baby my feet are like ice cubes
baby deep vein thrombosis
baby I'm on medication
baby that's why I [__] with my sock
song and I [__] with my black sock song
girl couple other things I should
probably tell
[Applause]
you my legs are pale they're almost kind
of light
blue there's a chance that I'll Dutch of
in
you oh and my stamina is not what it
used to be so when we bang you got to
get on top but I'll have my sock
song and I'll have my black sock song
girl and I
also I
also shave
[Music]
my
let me just say I want to address the
balls for just a second
uh yo I just want to tell anybody whose
partner insists that they take a
straight blade or a razor to their balls
does not understand the Topography of a
nut sack that's all I'm
saying yo that's like shaving your brain
you're going to Nick that [__] a
couple of times you know what I mean by
the way every guy in here will tell you
that first time you Nick your nuts you
have no idea how much that's gonna bleed
you know yo the first time you Nick your
nuts you're like am I about to bleed out
is this the end I put my feet above my
heart I called my dad I'm like am I
about to die man tell me what the
[__] yeah no not balls bro not
balls
[Applause]
shoulder
[Music]
all right one more quick one um okay so
uh I always find it funny man that
whenever you hear rappers or rock stars
sing about sex it's like everybody has a
huge dick and has sex all night long
everyone I'm G to tell you right now I'm
at an age where if you told me I want to
[__] all night long I'd be like that
sounds
terrible
one time in an episode of Friends that
I'll see you tomorrow you know what I
mean but this is what I would think
would be an honest song from a rock star
about what it would be like to have sex
with
him thanks for coming by you looking
mighty fine I'll
see you're wearing yoga
pants let's do some down faing
dogging
[Music]
rough come right in and lay your clothes
on the
[Music]
floor by the end of the night girl I'll
Have You Begging for
[Music]
more and are you ready ready for
some and are you ready for
some and are you ready for some oh I'm
getting pretty
tired are you ready for the best two
minutes of your life and are you ready
for the best two minutes of your
life love your life life life
[Music]
life come right in and lay your clothes
on the
floor that's not the
words lay you down put on a romantic
[Music]
song you won't have to listen to
Freebird that's 10 minutes too long
[Applause]
[Music]
I got start that verse over I'm [__]
up
already here we go I'm not like other
guys I won't waste your whole
[Music]
night I know you're busy girls
your schedule's not the only thing
that's
tight and are you ready for
some and are you ready for
[Music]
some and are you ready for some who
sorry about that let me get you a
towel I ready the best two minutes of
your
life and I best two minutes of your
[Applause]
life all right so now you guys will
actually be able to hear somebody who
knows how to play guitar um but here's
the deal so I I um you know there's a
certain part of my body that I'm very
proud of and um and so uh I wanted to
sing a little sexy song uh about it hold
on one
[Music]
second whenever you're
[Applause]
ready
on the day I was
born doctor said to
me you are a
vision of what a man should
[Music]
be legs
long thin
to you are the president of the dainty
ankle crew and I am
[Music]
I don't got one I got
[Applause]
[Music]
two I look good in high heel
shoes I am the D ankle
[Music]
crew now the good looking
women they come up to
me and say hey
man what's below the
knee yeah
ladies believe what you
heard when I take off my pants I look
like a sexy ass bird and I
yeah
I don't got one I got
[Music]
two I look good and high he
shoes I
know I know you ladies are jealous
too even Caitlyn Jenner calls me
Bruce I am the name tangle
[Music]
[Applause]
crew all
right now
uh he's laughing because we've actually
never played together before
so yeah that's hell true this is
all that's true yeah we never played
again so um all
right so Kurt let's um all right here we
go let me tell you one of the other
things one of the things that I love the
most about my wife is that she really
lets me be me right and um she also
people ask her a lot do you mind that he
smokes weed or so much weed and I think
she would tell you um she likes me
better when I'm hot uh because
I she's like when you don't smoke weed
for a month you never shut the [__]
up so I we wrote a couple of weed
Tunes um and uh let's start with this
[Music]
one
just
you know I like some
[Music]
weed let's start that again I'm a little
behind you
yeah
okay go like this when I'm supposed to
go
in
okay you know I like some weed
[Music]
weed it's got me super
high let's go get some
munchies pretty sure I can
[Music]
drive let's go to Taco
Bell get a Gord
Supreme
drive through
McDonald's fries in a
dream but I need
[Music]
sweets candy or
Bakers too many choices I
have I don't know what I
want I know I know
we God is Savor
live and
get some
Skittles
SK
[Applause]
ready
[Music]
SK wet up of my
keys I had them right
[Music]
here do you know where my shoes are
I don't know where my shoes
are you know
what we should just stay
here I'll call
[Music]
Postmates do you know where my phone
is hi I can't find where my phone
[Music]
[Applause]
is I bet you never played with someone
who's supposed to know what they're
doing and go tell me when I'm supposed
to say
something I don't know tell me when I'm
supposed to talk right now
tell listen guys uh you you know one of
the things that I love most about being
here is I have a ton of friends here and
I have a ton of creative friends who
like to come down and [__] around with
me and do weird [__] I have another one
of my friends in back uh ladies and
gentlemen from in sync Mr Chris
Kirkpatrick
[Applause]
everybody oh you are we out here come on
up
[Applause]
man come on up there he is Chris Kirk
Pat everybody that don't
[Applause]
hurt you're the only person here that I
don't understand how we're
friends like I sat here all night going
I can go out the back and no one will
ever know I was ever here just told Josh
don't call me up because this is getting
ridiculous
tonight hey guys I want to do a set of
out weed let me bring my ins sync buddy
up
hey come on up did you did you see him
put Dre's titty in his
mouth I don't think you saw it I I I
watched you I saw the whole thing and I
I just looked I was like I was going to
send some sympathy cards to Dre cuz I
know Dre was trying to be funny and yeah
I don't know what's going on right here
but y'all are out of control starting
with your
shirt are those Seahorses on your shirt
those are getos
all right well listen guys blend in
um so you ready to sing this song
no hey he by way seriously seriously I
like philli you know tonight is like I
don't know what you're on tonight but
like you're actually singing pretty good
like I wouldn't kick you off some of the
talent shows hey which is opposed to
most times where I'm us like that's my
friend good thing he's [__]
funny guess put your J job guess what
that's because I didn't take 100
milligram Edibles just
25 oh cool more weed jokes no I'm I'm a
responsible adult um okay so uh you
ready all right let's see what you
got sounds like one of our songs it
might be oh and by the way I changed a
couple
lyrics that's okay so tonight oh
[__] it was the first dat that my mom
said
up it was
uncomfortable oh I remember she told
me in her past life that she was a cat
and not only that she had three extra
toes she let her back hair grow she was
Raising five little kids from five
different dicks I really want to leave
but Mom will be mad at me so guess what
I'm going to need
[Applause]
weed it's early in the
morning in a long line you know to get
your car
a then one person in front of you she
seems really confused what's in a chai
are those muffins dry hey lady what the
[__] have you never been to
Starbucks there's a lot of an angry mob
going to sinkless jobs and I forgot the
words because I Chang them up but guess
what I don't need any more
[Applause]
weed there comes a day when you have to
go to your cousin's
weding and you're going to going going
we going to need weed maybe St your
toe run out of
D you don't like your ass so you take a
bar class whatever your reason
be it's just enough for me guess what
we're going to need
W
yeah
hey please don't tell any of the other
guys that I just did that are you
kidding me I'm live streaming with faton
right
now oh
[__] no the really weird part was I
thought we were doing this like three
weeks ago when you said we were yeah
yeah so I had the words memorizing over
and over in my head then they go hey we
need you to do this anti- drug thing in
Vegas can you come out and sing it's
going to be
me
nope Chris Kirk Patrick every R
[Music]
here you know some songs I just they
they catch me and something happens
during the middle of the day where I'll
write a quick little jingle and um so
this is the latest little one uh this
the latest little one um he knows what
the [__] what am I talking about
this is the latest little one I hope you
like
[Music]
it I don't even know what [__] song
you're playing right
now like guess sure doesn't sound like
anything I've ever played before what is
that sounds great okay
ready in my
car driving
around music's up I am lost in
sounds she pulls
up to my
right looks inside at just the wrong
time man she saw me pick a booger ah I
just picked a booger ah why I pick that
booger ah I just picked the booger ah
that's all I got
[Applause]
uh have a good day
yeah that's hard to play that one off
isn't it where you're
like um all
right like God Bless yeah
yeah no I was telling you you had
something up your nose I was just trying
to tell you um all right this next song
is something that happened to me at my
brother's
wedding and uh we'll see how it
[Music]
goes
had my brother's
wedding talking to the
DJ I was supposed to tell him about
songs that he could
play my brother like Li hip
hop and he likes classic
rock he could get down to some
R&B he likes to dance to some
pop DJ smiled at me he said don't you
worry
son I've done this aund times I
guarantee he will have
fun but can you please tell
me are there any
tunes I definitely should not play you
think we'll kill the mood and I said
whatever you do don't play Hotel
California I hate that [__]
song it's so goddamn
long and everyone here hates the Hotel
California not one single time
and not one [__]
[Music]
line the DJ stand right through
me his eyes went cold as ice and he said
well I've been playing that song at
weddings since
1979 and who do you think that you are
to change my
ways I'll play Hotel
California and I'll also play
YMCA that's all I got for that song
uh ladies and gentlemen Kurt Chambers
everybody let him here one
time yeah one more time for C everybody
one more
time
all right guys we're just going to wrap
it up with a couple quick songs and
we'll get everybody out of here um I uh
I can't believe
okay all right so we're gonna try in in
me fashion um it wouldn't be me doing
something like this without trying
something brand new so um yeah I know um
and I'm pretty sure I'm off I know the
lyrics to this song and we'll find out
real quick
so I have a very anxious dog this song
escalates A little
bit well I have got a very anxious dog
he doesn't like to be alone and when you
leave he loses his
mind he's broken out of every kennel we
bought but yeah he tears right through
them the last one he left the door on
our bed like a complete [__]
yeah what you
cherish oh he'll
[Music]
eat he knows what matters most to you
yeah did I
mention he opens doors
now my dog is Jason boy
is that the remote you need for your
brand new TV are these your favorite is
shoes you mean these that I chewed and
I'm going to [__] in the
corner I just a [__] in the corner I go
clean of my
mess oh it gets
weird
and lately things have taken a weird
turn like early this morning I woke up
with his paw on my mouth and he was
staring right at me yeah hard eye
contact he licked my
face slow and firm without consent yeah
are we doing this
now and I pick up your
[Music]
[__] I'm my dog's prison [__] I'm going
to [__] up your house yes I will yes I
will and I'm going to pee on your couch
yes I will yes I will and I'm going to
bark at a black
guy people will think that you're racist
yeah you'll get cancelled
thank
[Applause]
you hey will you hold this for
me you gonna be my Bobby
buet you can do
[Applause]
it
uh this next song I'm definitely going
to lose a few of you uh but I'd always
wanted to parody a song three times in
the same
song so here you go this one definitely
escalates
[Music]
also oh I should have had Kurt play this
one and I was
walking one day with my
buddy I was
walking one day with my puppy I saw my
buddy drinking coffee by
himself and so I called him to see what
he was doing he looked at the phone but
he didn't pick up dud that's me
[Applause]
it's me
calling you saw
[Music]
me me
calling I love my
grandma she's quite a know lady been in
a
wheelchair for 29 years and then one day
while watching
TV she reached for the remote
control fell out of her chair and now
[Music]
she she's
[Applause]
crawling you know
she
she's
crawling if you if you didn't like that
verse I'd walk the [__] out for the
next if you can't handle the comedy show
you know where it's not happening on the
[__] Street see you
[Applause]
later by the way I'm serious this next
verse is really going to bother you if
that one
did but this actually happened to me I
worked on a TV show
with a kid named Corky called life goes
on he was mentally
challenged and then one day he couldn't
remember his lines and the
director yelled what's wrong with him
dude he's
re he's
[Applause]
[__]
you know he's
re he's
Richard by the way I did this song last
night and people started to sing along
I'm like you can't sing along at this
point
[__] you yeah you can't the part you
can't sing along to you can't sing and I
want to say can I'm going to give you
guys a little comedy nerd [__] if I can
so when you do comedy is so much about
timing and your inflection and your
words and how you use them so I had to
really think about how I wanted to do
this part of the song so I've done it
two different ways I did it this way
doties
re right [__] and I did another way
I did I said dude
he's [__] now when I did it like
that people
booed and I'll tell you why because when
I say dude he's re you guys are making
the joke before I do I don't got to do
[__] so don't get mad at me you laughed
before I [__] said
it
four songs we're going to get out of
here babe I'm going to play a song at
the end
okay you're going to come on stage for
the last
song hey Bobby
Bobby H2O thank
you that's that quality H2O thanks
Bobby all
right so people ask me a lot why I don't
drink I don't drink because I make bad
life decisions when I drink uh you might
be here with one of yours tonight
uh so so we're just going to end it up
with these four songs and here we
go
George what do I is there already people
out there would you prefer two songs
instead of four four
three all right we're gonna do three and
here we go I um I I wrote the song after
I talked to a girl I went to high school
with and um I remember her because we
were the last two virgins that we knew
and so I remember calling her on the
phone and telling her we should be each
other's firsts and she was like why I
said first of all we're both virgins um
we went to preschool
together she was like what does that
mean I said well what that means is I've
known you forever you've known me
forever embarrassing things are going to
happen on the first time but we're like
buddies so I would rather something
embarrassing happens in front of you and
I'm sure you'd rather have something
embarrassing happen in front of me and
she was like you know you're right it's
a great idea we're going to be each
other's first so this song is how that
night
went and by the way guys like the song
doesn't go we [__] for 4 hours she
came 30 times like that's not the song
you know what I
mean that's not what I'm was singing
[Music]
about you said I'd be your first and
you'd be
mine we'd be together until the end of
time I laid her down and I kissed her
lips jeans on jeans and hips on hips
things were going just as we
planned she was my girl and I was her
man yeah right before we began well
I yeah
yeah
came in my
pants I came right in my pants oh please
don't tell my
friends that I came in my
pants and she was good to
me said it could happen to anyone she
said she'd give it a second
try she called the first one a dry
[Music]
run I set the mood just
right and to make sure what happened
last night didn't happen again I jerked
off four times before she came over and
then I jerked off two more times cuz I
was a
teenager and I could do that back then
and [__] felt
[Applause]
great hey yeah if I were you I'd put a
[__] cape on went into my room
superhero ooh and she looks so
pretty she unbutton my pants no mess
Hello
Kitty yeah and then my hand brushed her
[Music]
titty and I came on her
pants I came on her lime green pants but
what the [__] is is going on I'll never
see a vagina at this rate yeah years
went
by and we talk from time to time I met
her husband at the
reunion I really liked him he was a nice
guy he and I were about eight drinks
in when he smiled and he said you know
what
man I got to tell tell you and he said
with a
grin I know
you came in your
pants and that you came on her pants too
you know she tells all her
friends the guy on TV came in his pants
she started a Facebook
page and it's called sticky drawers
where you can tell funny stories about
sex oh and believe me she's told
yours I wanted Revenge I didn't know
what to
do we all got drunk and ended up in my
room they passed out
first that's a rookie
move so
I came on her pen
and then I came on his pants too and put
that on your Facebook
page with a big old [__]
[Applause]
you thank
you all right two quick ones you guys
remember the song by for non blond it
goes
I say all
right yeah [__] finish it up I like
it that's your part so obviously we do
not need to rehearse that
uh all right this happened to me when I
was a
kid woke up one morning when I was a kid
want woke up one morning when I was a
kid
wanted to get some breakfast
on maybe some eggs and
bakey and then I rub my eyes and put my
feet on the floor I look down the hall
parents door and I saw
something a little
pecul it was my mom and my dad and were
wrestling around and my mom she made
some pretty weird sounds and I screamed
at the top of my lungs get off my
mom and I said
hey
hey I said hey you know the words get
off my
[Music]
mom
thank you very
[Applause]
much let's bring the lovely and talented
Bethany ashon wolf out here Bethany come
on out
here are you not
right through here
BS come on up
[Applause]
here hey
thanks thanks for wearing my favorite
pants where am I going
what's happening now now we we talked
about Father's Day and how easy it is uh
to get a present and so this is just in
case can I have
[Applause]
Bobby thank you so much so this is just
in
case for anybody who actually does want
to get a gift for their man in their
life I thought I'd write a little song
um it's pretty
easy uh but so you know I would tell you
that Beth is an amazing Gift Giver like
she researches gifts she's one of those
people that'll research a gift for like
60 days and you opened it you're like
did you talk to my third grade teacher
like what the
[__] but the gifts are amazing and I
always tell her man you it took you 60
days you wasted 59
days gifts for guys are easy so this is
a song for anybody looking to get a gift
for that special man in their life I
hope this
helps couple people catching on to the
joke already all
right that's all right everybody look if
you're at my show and you're looking for
my jokes they're right [__]
here they're not if you're looking
around for them you're going to miss
them they're coming right the [__] out
your
face
okay song for anybody and then guys
thank you so much for coming out tonight
and this will be it for
[Applause]
us you're always so
thoughtful gifts on my special
day ask it in friends and family about
things that make me feel
great let me try to help
you Let Me ease your mind
cuz it's pretty
[Music]
easy you just have to ask
us we'll [__] tell
[Music]
you I just want to [__] and a
sandwich let me save you some time I'd
like a [__] and a sandwich I don't
need another [__] tie and I have one
wor cologne since the eighth grade you
and your sister use the couple's massage
I'd like a loja and a
sandwich at the same
time at the same
time timey timey timey timey timey timey
[Music]
[Applause]
time I like turkey on wheat
I like ham on
right but to make this day complete well
there's one more thing that I'd like to
try now I know when guys say try women
always think that we're talking about
anal cuz that's
[Music]
true just not this
time I just like a blow J and a sandwich
while I'm watching
TV turn on
ESPN little Predators
highights watching grown men skate
around in tight
[Music]
pants now I know on your special day I'd
give you anything that you
need trips jewelry your clothing I'd
bring the moon down to its
knees she doesn't have to tell me cuz I
know what she really
wants because she's told me
before I've still never done
it you'll see
why she says she wants me naked washing
dishes
in a Ryan Gosling
Mas Ro poats in the
rain telling all of
friends quotes from The Notebook over
again I wrote her every single
[Music]
day what Guns and Roses song is like
this patience all right let me see if I
can do this dude's voice at the end of
the show but we'll try we're going to
end it with patience and we're going to
get everybody out of
here all right patience
[Music]
[Applause]
right you ready baby I love
you thanks I love your
pants a [__] and a
sandwich
yeah a [__] and a sand
swich
yeah a [__] and a s I just want to
blow J hand
sandwich while I watch TV in bed I
promise not to get any crumbs on your
head I just want a blow job while I
watch some
TV that don't feel so fine to me in a
blow job yay and say
sandwich a
[__] a
[Applause]
[Music]
sandwich thank you all so much for
coming out here tonight I had a great
time with
you
a